so coronavirus has happened and it's
been a little bit of a strange few weeks
that's my hot take strange few weeks
among the other things have happened
YouTube has become flooded with
information on training from home with
bodyweight and of course this is a good
thing
bodyweight training is a fantastic way
to build muscle and who don't have
access to a gym then it's a perfect
substitute for using weights and things
however the downside of this is that
with so much information out there it
can be a bit misleading for newcomers
and that's not to say that anybody is
intentionally putting out the wrong
information or does know they're talking
about etc it's just that there's a lot
of conflicting advice on YouTube and
this stems from the fact that there are
lots of different approaches to
bodyweight trading lots of different
types of bodyweight training and if you
choose the wrong type of training for
the goals that you have in mind then you
won't get the results that you want and
so in this video I'm going to break down
for you the different types of
bodyweight training and how to employ
them to maximum benefit for your
training goals
[Music]
so to start with you have your basics
you have push-ups pull-ups sit-ups etc
these are your fundamental building
blocks of bodyweight training and
they're what a lot of programs will be
written around and a lot of the workouts
that you'll find on YouTube revolve
around doing a whole bunch of press ups
whole bunch of pull-ups sit-ups etc in a
kind of circuit this is fine if your
goal is to burn fat to tone muscle to
generally improve your metabolic
conditioning however it's not useful
particularly if you want to build big
muscle lots of strength or general
performance and the reason for that is
that things like push-ups perform for 10
to 20 reps even are not really enough to
stimulate a lot of muscle growth if
you're used to lifting 150 kilograms on
the benchpress then doing some push-ups
that's really not going to cut the
mustard basically when you do push-up
you're only lifting a portion of your
own upper body weight and this isn't
enough to send the correct stimulus to
optimize muscle growth
the three main triggers for muscle
growth as many of you all know are
mechanical tension muscle damage and
metabolic stress mechanical tension
happens when the muscle picks up the
fact that it's contracting through the
Meccano receptors and it releases growth
factors in response to that which then
encourage growth muscle damage occurs
when the muscle cells undergo tiny micro
traumas and then get built back up
thicker and stronger and finally
metabolic stress occurs when you kind of
pull blood and oxygen and metabolites in
the muscle by using a high rep range and
this then floods them with more growth
factors that encourage growth and of
course you can also improve your neural
Drive which is muscle fiber recruitment
and that occurs when you attempt to use
the maximum amount of force in your
muscle that trains you to use your
muscle as efficiently as possible and
that's kind of separate to hypertrophy
push-ups on their own done stopping
before failure won't trigger any of
these different things that's because as
I say they just aren't challenging
enough you're not going to contract the
muscle enough you're going to be using
the thickest and biggest fast twitch
muscle fibers and you're not going to be
getting along enough to cause a lot of
metabolic stress but I can say this is
fine if you just want to turn up
slightly and if you want to burn fat and
calories in which case using a
bodyweight circuit is perfect so if your
aim is to get kind of a toned body for
the beach and you're not interested in
building big size or particularly
massive strength or explosiveness then
you're a Jay wick style metcon workout
sir
it's really useful but if you want to
build size and strength like a
bodybuilder if you usually curl weights
in the gym then you're gonna need to
train more like a bodybuilder using your
bodyweight that means you need to
slightly increase the challenging you to
make the amount of resistance greater
and you also need to isolate the muscle
group more so for instance if you
normally do lots of curls then the
closest thing to that might be lots of
chin-ups if that doesn't provide enough
of a challenge then you might want to do
a one-armed chin up and what that will
do is double the amount of weight that
you're putting onto that arm what's at
the same time isolating the bicep far
more and if you can't do a one-arm to
chin up then you can assist yourself you
see a lot of people at the moment on
YouTube using a towel around one side of
they use with their left hand whilst
they do one arm - chin-ups with their
right hand and that way they can just
balance themselves make it that little
bit easier the left hand whilst keeping
the focus nicely on the bicep until it
goes to failure in bodybuilding the aim
is to focus on a specific muscle group
to isolate that muscle group because
that allows you to take it to failure
and beyond as I talked about in my
previous video when you go to the point
of failure not only does that maximize
the amount of metabolic stress create
the pump and the burn which signals the
kind of psycho plasmic growth that
bodybuilders are interested in and
improves your muscle endurance but at
the same time it also forces you to use
the faster twitch muscle fibers because
these slate rich muscle fibers are
fatiguing and dropping out so you can
get there by doing huge massive sets of
bodyweight training large long sets of
press ups and squats which has a whole
bunch of other benefits as I talked
about in my previous video or you can
get there by really isolating the muscle
group targeting that one area so that
that gives up first and then you drop
out of that movement the other example
I've seen people doing is training their
shoulders by putting their hands onto
parallettes putting their legs up
against the wall and then performing as
many shoulder presses as many handstand
presses as they can using a large range
of motion whilst the wall supports the
legs that's difficult enough that they
can get to about 1215 reps to failure
and on top of other techniques that can
be enough of an intense workout to
trigger some kind of growth however it's
not going to be the equivalent of
building max strength in the same way
that you might do with your 80% on 90
percent one rep max doing a military
press for instance or a squat the
problem is that we just can't create
that kind of challenge with our body
weight alone
[Music]
so yeah even though you might be using
90% of your own body weight by doing
these upside-down wall handstand presses
that's still not going to be challenging
enough the closest we can come is to
increase the challenge in a number of
other ways by adapting our bodyweight
training further and we can do this by
either increasing the lever or by using
unilateral movements you might do a
unilateral movement by doing a pistol
squat likewise you can make a push-up
much more difficult by doing a one-armed
push-up or you can move your arms
further down your body turning it into
something more like a Maltese push-up or
a pseudo plants pushup and this is
increasing the length of the lever so
that your anchor point to the ground is
further away from the weight which
therefore makes it feel heavier so if
you pick up a chair and you hold the leg
right at the top then it's gonna feel
relatively light if you pick up a chair
and you hold it right at the bottom of
the leg and then point it forwards it's
gonna feel much heavier because you've
created a lever we can use our body to
create levers and therefore increase the
challenge while still targeting certain
muscle groups to a certain extent but
this is where we start to slightly veer
into the territory of skills training
and bodyweight skills training
calisthenics is completely different
from the kind of bodyweight training
I've been talking about for building
muscle size and strength yeah as much as
they're very useful if you just want to
build size and strength performing wall
handstand push-ups using a leg against
the wall and using parallettes that is
not by any means elite bodyweight
training
elite the bodyweight training would be
the guys like Sai monster strength who
can do crazy handstand push-ups and then
slowly lower themselves into a full
planche and then continue with planche
push-ups
that's elite bodyweight strength so
we're talking things like plants like
manna like the Maltese like handstands
like handstand press ups these things
require a lot of strength yes but
they're not optimal for building pure
strength pure max strength or for
building hypertrophy for building a big
physique certainly not to begin with so
I love handstands and that's something
I'm really working on at the moment they
build mobility they build core strength
and preception
that's precisely the problem if your aim
is to build muscle size or muscle
strength so when I do a handstand it's
not my shoulders that are giving out
it's the fact that my legs are tipping
over slightly towards the front because
I don't have enough core strength to
keep myself stable for long enough or
it's the fact that I have quite enough
reception to know exactly where my legs
are maybe our lack of mobility and my
shoulders I do to keep them straight
enough so that I'm not perfectly
stacking my joints all these things
factored into the reason but I can't do
a handstand for that long while multiple
sets of perfect handstand push-ups which
is why I fail so if I was just using
that to build strength
it wouldn't work because I wouldn't be
able to get to that point of failure I
wouldn't be able to create enough
mechanical tension or muscle damage in
any specific muscle group in order to
cause it to grow optimally the same
thing happens even with something like
the pursuit a planche pushup because
there's so many different muscles
involved using your core you're using
the anterior delts a lot you're using
your straight arm strength your scapular
strength your serratus muscles when you
combine all those things together one of
them is going to fatigue 70% and that'll
be why you can't do the movement so your
pecs might still have more on the tank
but because your obliques have failed
during your one-armed push-up you now
can't do any more repetitions so you're
not gonna get that optimal growth
fantastic for building core strength and
proprioception for athletic performance
yes and I highly recommend this kind of
training but if your main goal is just
to build size if you want to be a body
builder or if you want to build a
maximum strength then this is no longer
optimal unfortunately bodyweight
training is not weight training and
there are a lot of differences which
mean that it's not going to perfectly
replace any training modality that you
have in the gym that's why I like
combining different training methods
because that we can get all the benefits
even if you found some weird variation
of the bodyweight squat that made it
feel as difficult you still wouldn't be
creating the same amount of pressure on
the bones or the connective tissue that
helps to increase bone density and
strengthen the tendons it's just a
different thing and likewise you can't
mimic the kind of price epson and the
transverse strength and the stability
necessary to perform a one-armed push-up
by doing simply compound moves or body
building exercises so what's the answer
then basically we need to take the form
of bodyweight training that's the
closest to what we want to accomplish
and then hope for the best
so if you want to tone up lose fat then
using those metabolic conditioning
bodyweight circuits absolutely fine
great idea if you want to build as much
muscle size as possible then I recommend
going either for very high rep push-ups
and air squats etc which does have a lot
of other benefits which I talk
about in my previous video or using
isolation training trying to isolate the
muscle group as much as possible trying
to make it as heavy as possible and then
aiming for 12 to 15 reps to technical
failure if you want to build as much
strength as possible and emulate
powerlifting at home then you want to
make the movements as difficult as
possible this is gonna be the hardest to
emulate at home but using things like
planche push-ups and maybe pistol squats
we can get somewhere close finally if
you're interested in functional strength
and proprioceptive balance and
explosiveness then great news you can
use all of those cosmetic skills for
explosiveness of course you want to use
this prior metric moves like clapping
push-ups and that will be perfect for
improving your athletic performance the
good news is we don't lose muscle really
quickly in fact I think Jeff and if I
talked about this recently studies show
that you only need to include one
strength training program a week to
maintain your muscle what's more is that
many of the adaptations that occur
during training mean that you gain
muscle much more easily when you do lose
it you increase the number of my own
nuclei the nuclei in your muscle cells
and that makes it easier to grow more
muscle more quickly they don't disappear
when you stop training
likewise you change gene expression and
that doesn't change likewise tendon
strength stays around for much longer
than muscle strength so even if you do
lose some strength you'll gain it back
when you return to the gym focus on some
different aspects of your training to
improve your metabolic conditioning and
your work capacity or to improve your
prior section and your balance so that
when you return to the gym
you've got some other tricks up your
sleeve that will enhance your training
as you gain back that strength in a
matter of weeks and months alternatively
my strategy is to combine these
different methods into one workout or
one program I like to use a kind of
reverse pyramid structure where I'll put
the most difficult and challenging and
complex movements at the start of the
workouts that's why I work on my skills
training then I'll move more onto
isolation movements unilateral movements
and then end with high repetitions of
simple movements like the push-up and
the pull-up to build the pump to
increase work capacity to increase the
number of capillaries fueling my muscle
with blood etc and this to me gives you
the kind of best of all worlds because
not only are you increasing your prior
section in your control but you're also
then combining that with high
repetitions they're going to force you
to use those faster twitch muscle fibers
and to fatigue pretty much everything in
all your muscles so bodyweight training
can be absolutely fantastic
it certainly can for now replace your
gym training but you need to approach it
in the right way take whichever of those
methods appeals most to you or combine
them in a unique way as I've suggested
here I hope you found that useful and
interesting guys I'll be returning to my
usual scheduling very soon I've got lots
of topics to tackle such as my Batman
recovery video etc if you did enjoy it
then please leave a like and share it
around that helps me out immensely and
subscribe for more like this if you
enjoy this kind of combined approach to
training then you might like my ebook
and training program super functional
training and you can find that in a link
in the description down below I've put a
big discount on that because people are
stuck at home and they've got nothing to
do so hopefully that gives you something
to read alternatively I also created a
free bodyweight program and I will link
to that in the description down below as
well and it takes the approach that I
talked about last in this video we are
combining high repetitions of simple
movements along with more complex
movements at the start of the workout
hope you guys are all staying safe and
healthy I know it's a rough time but
just got to focus on the positives so
try something new explore new avenues
we've got training and keep punching
thanks a ton for watching and I'll see
you next time bye for now
I'd also like to take this moment to
announce another new initiative I've
just set up an exclusive invitation-only
bio near Facebook group this is a
mastermind group slash brain trust for
discussing unusual training methods
brain training
recent research secret projects here on
the site and more my hope is that we can
put our heads together and crowd saw
some exciting new ideas and concepts to
take our performance further I want to
keep this group small and focused to
maintain a high quality of discussion so
now it will only be open to patrons and
the brain trust tier the five
dollar-a-month tier this should prevent
the group from being flooded with the
same questions and will help to grow and
support the channel all you need to do
is sign up as a patron then scroll down
to the link which is there as a post
I'll get a notification and I'll then
approve your membership as soon as I'm
able to I put more information in the
description down below I look forward to
seeing you there